[Music]
All right. So, definition of humor. Who
here thinks they have a good definition
of humor?
I think it's funny and also like finding
like the funnies in like everyday things
and like making negative situations
funny.
Okay. So, making negative situations
funny and stuff. Well, if we take a look
at Random House dictionary, what they
say is a comic, absurd, or inongruous
quality causing amusement.
It's kind of interesting. So, there's no
real
distinct mention of funny or even
laughter. I mean, it's kind of covered
in the idea of comic, but it also
includes things that are absurd or maybe
silly and inongruous. So, this idea of
maybe just something outside of the
norm. And that's kind of really one of
the key takeaways that I want you to
understand about humor is that it
definitely includes funny and jokes and
humor and laughter, but it doesn't
necessarily mean that it has to be that
way. It's kind of like that logic
problem that you had in elementary
school where said that all lions are
cats. Oh, an adorable picture. A but not
all cats are lions, right? I love that
picture. As much as they want to be,
they're not all lions. And that's how
humor is. So humor, we have this giant
bubble of what humor could be. Things
that cause amusement, cause joy with
people. And within that, there is
comedy. That's one subsection of it.
Within comedy, we do have jokes. Within
jokes, we have things like my golf game
because it's giant joke at this point.
But we have this entire sphere of humor
that also is included. That's things
like starting presentations off with uh
with music or in an email starting
things off with hello fellow earthlings
instead of greetings people or that kind
of thing. It's just having a unique spin
on things. Doesn't have to be
necessarily hilarious, but if it causes
a smile or causes amusement in the other
person, it's humor.
[Music]